I'm glad to be here
I wouldn't have it any other way and uh
I'm grateful to be doing the job that I
love Brendan Fraser opens up about his
big acting return what fans are lovingly
calling his Renaissance I was never that
far away
[Music]
I guess I supposed to say you can't get
rid of me that easy
the actor is variety's latest cover star
alongside Darren Aronofsky the director
of his latest project the whale the
film's trailer is yet to be released but
it's already receiving tons of Oscar
buzz and Brandon's a big reason why it's
exciting in September the actor received
a six-minute standing ovation at the
Venice Film Festival Brandon was visibly
moved by the audience's reaction to his
performance
all right
he tells variety of that moment it felt
so affirming I was emotional because it
was acknowledgment that what we did is
making an impact and that kind of
response feels completely new in my
professional life
Brendan of course burst onto the scene
in the 90s with hit films like Encino
Man check out the fresh snacks wheezing
the juice
buddy
he then went on to star in his biggest
Blockbuster to date The Mummy
did the basics are pretty much
when I would have relied on to see me
through this picture and that is to show
up on time to have a good relationship
with people and and uh and work hard
this could pave the way for uh a whole
new series of mum pictures who knows and
that it did with Brendan always working
steadily but eventually he decided he
needed a Hiatus from Hollywood quote I
know that the time I needed to take for
personal reasons and for family reasons
was all time well spent and the industry
changed a great deal from the time I
stepped back in 2009 or 2010 no matter
what it was I never thought about giving
it up I'm an actor I don't know what
else I would do nothing comes easy and
if ever if this was easy everybody would
be doing it so that's why we're here
and now Brendan's back in demand more
than ever with his lead role as Charlie
in the whale and Darren he knew Brendan
was the right and only man for the job
it was a really long search
to find Brendan I didn't really want to
wake up in the morning and make this
movie with anyone else up till when I
met Brendan when he left my office after
our first meeting I felt it
so what does Brendan think when it comes
to all the awards season Buzz well he
humbly says nothing's happened yet so
check in with me about that later if
something does
[Music]
foreign
[Music]